Hello Freak bitches.
I think it's a great idea,
but I think the world is being starved from a Charlie Murphy TV show.
That's what I'm saying.
So when he used to follow you.
Yeah,
we got that,
we got that and we also got the other show I'm doing and the thing is going to
be rich,
fallen asleep,
but
there was the whole digital thing.
We get ready to build up,
you know when it's going to be a camera,
the whole digital thing.
Yeah.
We get married.
Only a man such as Charlie Murphy can get away with saying that,
you know the whole digital thing.
That's your thing that's going on right now.
You open that up,
you build up my whole digital department of,
you know my,
didn't you start a podcast?
I am.
That's all them.
All in the makings.
But I only could do one thing at a time.
And what I was focusing on this year was writing that movie.
I just finished writing and you know,
getting ready to do the TV show.
I we were doing 20 episodes over the next six weeks.
Wow.
I'm focusing on those two things and once that's done,
boom,
then it's onto the next,
then the next area.
I'm not,
I don't sit back on my hunches at all.
Definitely not.
You got DVDs,
books and movies,
everything.
And then you got to your website where the wife man.
Yeah.
I keep working hard.
I'll have one eventually.
You know,
it said it's kind of be hard to marry after your wife dies.
What does it feel?
It's not going to be hard to marry.
It's hard to be single,
right?
Being single.
It sucks,
man.
It doesn't,
especially if you get kids,
because like I have to sneak the APP stacks,
man.
Come on man.
You go through that when you were in high school,
but if you,
if you're,
if you're a person that you're married to,
happens to pass away or whatever,
you can't bring chicks around and bone them.
You can't do that man.
Especially not being filed or your lab slip.
You can't sneak them up sitting room,
any of that.
Because when they come in and if you have a daughter,
she's going to go,
Hey,
what?
Who?
Who was that?
That's so my daughter.
Then she goes right over to the person and start monopolizing them.
Who are you?
What are you doing here?
And she makes sure,
so you're having a sleep over and no she's not.
So you have to sneak.
Yeah man.
Being singles know after you were married for years is wack.
Well,
I was married for years,
so I want to be,
you know,
the lifestyle,
my wife is gone,
but the lifestyle,
yeah,
I missed that man.
Definitely being single sucks.
Make single checks.
Don't cook for you.
You don't want them to cook.
You don't even trust them.
Especially if they suggest to you is exactly what spaghetti and no,
no,
no.
You can't.
You know,
you got to be married to trust them,
to enjoy those things.
It's also got be hard when you're on the road,
you know you're on the road constantly.
It's hard to spend time with someone to get to know them.
Once you take them with you and you can't take somebody with you,
they have their own life going on.
And if you say,
come with me,
you get basically saying quit your job,
but I'm not telling no one to quit the job.
Quit your job and come with me.
Oh No,
I'm not doing that.
So it's hard man.
Especially when you barely know them,
you know,
cause that's really what it is until live with someone.
You
don't really don't know him that well.
You do,
but you don't.
You don't,
you don't live with them.
That's a key part.
And that's when they can get to know you talking about a year of living with
someone,
I mean living with someone,
do you got,
you got to say at least three years cause something's going to have three years
is a good time [inaudible] at some point.
Right,
right,
right.
Hmm.
Did you get to know the person?
Yeah.
So you know,
that's,
that's like my,
that's the paradox in my life right now.
You know,
people were looking go ease,
everyone likes him,
he's doing great in his business and then it's show business and blah blah blah.
Yes,
that's good.
But that's not real life.
That's a job.
A real lag is my family.
My real life is when you come home at night with lights go off,
you ain't on stage and that's the part where there's you go,
there's a big hole because my wife is gone and it's not as simple as one would
think,
oh,
it's hard.
It's harder than you would think.
As far as friends,
somebody to to fill in that area.
Of course there's plenty of people would say,
oh,
I would do it outcome,
but it's not the person you want.
You have to be very careful.
You have around the children.
Yeah,
man.
Oh,
I want to slap a few of these checks.
Okay.
How can I move in with you and take care of your children?
Really you will.
You you a horror.
The horror.
What are you guys with that horror,
horror,
horror or woman who was at the best of just getting confused by the accent?
I thought it was an inside joke that I was missing out on
the
tuition for your brother and while you're actually touring as a comedian,
that's gotta be really hard.
Yeah.
Meg.
Nick says,
I got my kids with me out of here,
man.
I got my son son's in your living room right now.
Yeah,
I got my kids out here with me right in there and you know,
schools giving a start,
so they're going to be with me till September.
[inaudible] taking them back home,
hanging out with him that week.
School starts then you know that that was back when we get got to New Jersey.
That's than just,
you're still in the live in New Jersey and Pennsylvania too.
But this was in Philly last weekend,
man.
Yeah.
I live in,
have a of Strausberg.
No,
but I'm just saying once that goes back into effect,
I'm still going to be coming.
I gotta come back out of here,
work on the show.
I got to go to Europe.
I got to go to Cuba.
Just said it's the jar Rahab,
so I can't complain.
I'm glad I had the job.
But that's the part of it that the fact that their mother is that here.
That makes it really rough.
Yeah.
Automatic.
If I was leaving you with your mom was I wasn't even,
I bet.
Yeah,
that's right.
I'm not leaving with you.
What's your mom's leaving you with nannies,
right.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause my whole family lives out here on the west coast or whatever.
And because I'm at the kind of person that leans on people like that,
I appreciate your help,
but I'm going to ask them for it.
And if you don't offer it,
I'm,
I'm not going to complain about it.
I'd do it myself.
Yep.
And that's how I raised kids.
You know what I'm saying?
I got paid,
my name's,
I don't ask somebody to help me out.
I'll do what I gotta do.
But at the same time,
there's a feeling that goes along with that and don't feel good,
you know,
as do you do like video conferencing with your kids.
You try to do as much as possible and Skype and all that.
But that's good.
You know what I'm saying?
My kids young man,
I got a five year old daughter,
you know,
and I just don't want this.
The thing you do is to support them and be the thing that,
that,
uh,
disables them.
I'm like,
when they grow up,
Yay.
My father was never home.
He was always working and blah,
blah,
blah.
And that's the reason why,
you know,
my life went this way.
That's my fear.
You know,
I work with that one constantly.
that's the fear of every father.
How much time can you spend in doing what you want to do for a living?
The more your kids man,
cause if you don't do it,
he's getting moldy,
moldy or whatever.
You don't teach him,
he's going to learn somewhere else.
You know?
And it may be,
you know,
warped sense of,
uh,
like me for instance,
when I was growing up,
you know,
my dad was always at work always.
I was seeing one day a week Saturday.
And usually that wasn't,
you know,
to be next to it.
That's what you was getting your ass whipped for,
what you did during,
during the week.
You know what I'm saying?
Yes.
When you dad showed up to whip your ass and sanity.
As a result.
When I grew up and became a man,
when it came time for me to deal with women,
I learned how to deal with women by listening to guys that were in the street
bombs,
guys,
nick t-bones,
slick and big and whatever.
And because of that,
the first couple of relationships I had with women,
I was abusive.
Dude,
man,
I would think of think what you're talking back to me.
The answers I'm supposed to hit you because that's what slick told me.
That's not doing what you're supposed to do.
If your dad is there to teach you that,
you know better.
But if you don't grow up with that around,
grew up with something else because you're going to be seeking analogy.
You Go,
you go out and do the wrong thing.
You know?
So that's what I think about what my kids that I want to,
you want to be at and make sure you did it.
Just deliver all the lessons they need.
But then when you go to half my team is gone.
Is that not to do about that?
It makes it real scary,
especially when you start looking at,
well,
all the people who are talking about,
they want to be the replacement.
You must be out of your mind.
You think I'm a bring you,
bring you around.
I mean,
our relationship is fine over here,
but do you think it would bring you,
I think we found the show.
This is the show,
this show,
the show was doing.
So Comma,
and what's really fucking going on in your life now?
Well,
that's why,
that's why the show I'm doing,
it's not the adopted son.
Exactly.
See me,
my kids,
man.
Right.
And I'm,
I'm single.
I'm going to have the same challenges as I have in my real life and I could
definitely bring it,
uh,
experience.
Do you bring,
do you ever,
do you ever have done it?
But my kids don't.
Kids don't like to,
uh,
be at work with you.
Right.
You know,
for no longer than five minutes.
When they get there,
they check it out,
but okay,
then where's the toys that,
where is my world?
Right,
right,
right.
Where's the kitty things?
So I had my kids with me on the road when their mom mom was alive,
but since she's passed away,
I haven't had them with me because I'm a horrible,
uh,
fun buddy for a kid.
We go to Seattle.
Oh,
let's go,
let's go check out to dinner.
Then I'll be in the room,
go,
well if I go there,
I'm going to have to sign autographs and take pictures.
I'm not going to be able to do it the way you guys.
So it's gone.
It's gone.
You don't go to just like go to Disneyland.
I have to go on certain days,
man.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't go when it's,
when it's peak,
you know everybody's dead because then I become goofy or,
or,
or Mickey Mouse.
You know what I'm saying?
To the people who came here on vacation,
you know,
you have the day we were staying on a vine on 17,
17 branch resort hotel called the Red Berry.
Right.
It's right on the walk of fame and all that.
My kids in the hotel looking out the balcony,
we want to go for a walk.
And I said,
okay,
you can go for a walk with the nanny.
It's no way I want to walk on the walk of fame in broad daylight with my kids.
And I know that that's a tourist attractions.
People on buses,
you know,
driving around here,
the tour buses,
driving around on star searches or what have you.
And if you from Kansas or wherever you may be from him and you go to Hollywood
and you see someone you've seen on television,
when are you going to do,
you're going to go crazy and you should.
So that's why I was like,
you better stay in your room because if you go down there with your kids it's
not going to be,
have you ever thought about it like disguises,
like blonde way?
Absolutely not.
I refused
the blue.
That actually happened.
Patrick Stewart,
they brand new,
they Patrick's Day parade a week before that,
it was a blackout in my town,
had lost power at my house for like a week,
staying in New York and the London hotel.
So Saint Patrick's Day was during and we got it.
I wasn't,
I'm an Irish even though my name is Murphy,
I don't,
and I'll be aware of when Saint Patrick's Day is coming up,
you know,
so last name is Rogan and I don't know why it's coming up.
I walked outside with,
you know,
my two kids and he was walking around Manhattan supposedly going to walk over to
central park and I see all the Hoopla and fit man.
And I'm like,
Oh,
it's St Patrick's Day.
Do you kids want to go to the Saint Patrick's Day parade?
And it's like,
Yeah Daddy.
Because they had never been.
I walked him,
just me and my two kids,
man.
I walked him up to the crowd,
put my daughter on my shoulder and we were watching the parade and heard
somebody go,
Yo,
that's Charlie Murphy,
that's Charlie Murphy.
Then it started from this side,
the left and the right and then you see the people looking at you and they're
coming forward.
And my daughter started screaming,
man,
because it was a lot of people and they had expressed,
pressed on the wall,
the building
screaming,
and my daughter's screaming from fear,
man,
I'm holding my son's arm.
And it had to just turn it to like an animal man.
Get the f out of here.
This just push through the crowd and I look my kids,
man,
and as I'm doing it,
I'm going,
you're an idiot.
What made you think that you could stand on fifth avenue in,
in broad daylight on Saint Patrick's day and of crowd,
which the children,
and that was the safe thing to do,
but I forgot for that one split second.
What I do full live,
it came,
you know what I'm saying?
It can't make the bay me.
There's
blonde wig.